it's okay
is it the Galla thing that you
3:30 so I'm going to start
second after class okay folks couple of
things you know what's coming first
right how many of you have not picked a
company to Value
yet I'm not going to follow up I I will
assume you will get there because next
week is an odd week we don't have class
on Monday but we do have class on
Tuesday it's the first Tuesday I've T in
40 years at NYU I don't like teaching
Monday Tuesdays but this semester
because the way the semester started on
a Tuesday this is how they making it up
is there's a Tuesday class from 3:30 to
4:45 in this room so come to class so
there's both Tuesday and Wednesday so
next week we have two sessions back to
back but you do have a long weekend and
the nice thing about President Day
weekend is it comes with no
obligations you don't have to call your
mother that's Mother's
Day you don't have to hang out with
family that's Thanksgiving day I'm not
even sure what you're supposed to do on
President's Day which means you have a
wide open weekend a three-day weekend
and here's what I'd like you to do pick
a
company find a risk free rate so
somebody remind me again how AA how do
you how do you come up with the risk-
free rate what do you have to first do
um you
check what pick a currency right don't
go checking stuff until you picked a
currency once you pick a currency then
go looking for government bonds in that
currency and then check to make sure the
Government Bond is default free if it's
not some cleaning up to do right risk
free rate what about Equity risk
premiums what I what do I require to get
an equity risk
premium the region you need to know
where the company operates so go looking
through the footnotes and somewhere in
there you'll see a geographic breakdown
you might not like the way they've done
it I might not like the way they do but
you got to live in the world you're in
and do the equity risk bream based on
what they break the world down into so
you got a risk free rate we got an
equity risk free what's the third and
final number I need to get a cost of
equity bet there's so much mythology
about beta that I want to dispel today
because especially if we've taken
multiple Finance classes that that
mythology gets embedded in your head but
remember why do we need a beta to get a
measure of relative risk so let's step
back and so today's start of the class
test is going to be about the very idea
of
beta what is this beta go to it goes
into cost effect according cost of
capital and we're trying to do intrinsic
valuation
right but if you've taken a finance
class what do we use to estimate
betas returns which come from stock
prices which comes from the market and
already you can see one reason a lot of
oldtime value investors don't like bet
you say they say look our job in
intrinsic values not be driven by the
market but to make judgments and if you
make take the bait and get it from
markets aren't you in fact using a
market price based estimate of risk when
you should be using an intrinsic value
measure of
risk so if you use betas around you know
value investors there are a lot of
people who don't like betas for lots of
different reasons and if you happen to
already have a point of view on betas I
want you to dig a little deeper and
right now you might not be ready to make
a choice but think about it what it is
about betas you don't like and I list
some of the things the first is maybe
you don't think you should adjust
discount rates for risk at
all you think this whole exercise and
risk adjustment is just like Naval
gazing every company should have the
same cost of equity there are enough
people out there who believe this that
they think there should be no risk of
every company gets a 10% cost of equity
the second is you know you don't like to
use a measure of risk based on past
prices you think there should be a risk
measure but you think it should be based
on earnings or something more
fundamental the third might be you're
okay using prices but remember the
implicit assumption we make when we use
prices to get a beta we're assuming the
marginal investors are Diversified and
all you care about is the risk you
cannot diversify maybe that's the thing
you have issue with you know maybe you
should be looking at total
risk or maybe you're okay with both
price prices and diversified investors
but you just don't like the fact that
regression betas are all over the place
you pick a different index you get a
different
number I'm not going to make you pick
for the moment because I'm going to let
you kind of ponder because if you don't
like betas I'd like to know why because
I can fix it that right there is a
solution to almost every one of these
problems we'll talk more about this but
in your finance class remember you asked
to run a beta and it was very simple
right the Returns on the stock against
Returns on the market index the slope of
the line is a beta you came out of the
class said this is
easy then you get on a Bloomberg
terminal and you type in the word beta
for your company I hope you guys have
got your Capital iQ going and at some
point the Bloomberg terms of the
undergraduates where are they are they
in this go get on one you need to for
only about 10 minutes find your company
assuming you picked a company and you
all said you did so I'm going to take
you at your word type in the word beta
you'll see a beta page for the company
returns of the stock returns of the
market index we're going to dig a little
deeper into that Bloomberg beta but what
Bloomberg allows you to do actually is
change the
index change the time period change the
returns from daily to weekly to monthly
and what you're going to see is as you
change make those choices you're going
to get different
betas you can use only one we'll talk
about how that process plays out when
analysts do this but if you take a
company like Petr
brass I can take the local listing in
Brazil and run it against aesa that's a
default index for Brazil and I get a
beta the beta that I get is
1.6x but Petr brass has an ADR list in
the US an ADR is just a company list in
the US trading in dollar terms and when
I look up the regression for petr's ADR
it runs it against the S&P 5 and it
comes up with the bait of 1.98
so you're Ving Petr brass which of these
two numbers should you
use what do you
think toil
company I guess where where is it
getting that's an equity risk Prem
question do not ask that question
because then you're mixing up what
should be driving Equity risk premiums
with what drives beta beta is about
business right it's an all company the
fact that it's in Brazil shouldn't drive
the beta because then you'll be double
counting country
risk it's an unfair question because
these are both crappy
bers right why they crappy bers remember
your statistics when you run a
regression you get a slope right and If
This Were A statistics class what do you
train to put in Brackets under that
slope the standard error basically
telling the world look guys I'm not
certain it's a practice we conveniently
forget right after we we leave the
statistics class and become consultants
and we tell companies this is what will
happen if we told them the standard
error and what we know they're never
going to pay
us we're going to talk today about the
problem with regression Bas when you
take one period you take one stock you
do it against the index because there's
a heck of a lot of gaming that's going
to go on here right remember we talked
about bias at the start of this class
let's suppose I asked you a question
what do you let's suppose you want to
find Petr brass to be cheap because
you're trying to sell Petr brass to a
client which beta are you going to latch
on
to you want the higher beta you want to
because remember you want to convince
them it's cheap so basically you want
the value to be higher than the price
you want a higher value to get a higher
value do you want
to you want to go with the lower beta
right so if you want to make the value
higher you pick the lower beta this game
is just a game you're going to pick the
beta that best withs your
story and people say what choice do I
have to today I will give you a choice
where instead of running a regression
and trying to figure out what to do
we'll talk about a way you can get
around the statistical problem so let's
get the process rolling let's go back to
where we were in the lecture
notes and talk about
B
so I was Tau B this the same way you
are I was told run a regression take the
slope of the line and said that's a beta
it's a horrifically bad way to think
about betas because it makes beta into a
statistical number right something you
look
up in fact I'm going to argue that there
are three reasons you should never trust
a regression beta almost every beta you
see in s from Yahoo finance from
Bloomberg is a regression beta first is
what I talked about standard error
problem you're going to see how big that
can be at least for some companies
second is your beta backward looking or
forward looking
it has to be backward looking because
your returns came from The Last 5 Years
the last two years you can't do returns
for the next two because you don't know
what they'll be it is backward looking
and if your company's business mix is
changing it might not be the right beta
for the company that you're valuing
today and third it also reflects the
fact that when you estimate a beta
you're building in The Leverage we to
talk about how Deb affects betas into
the Beta And if that debt makes changes
your beta should change as well
so I'm going to start this process off
with a regression beta for a company
called
GoPro
GoPro basically they produce cameras for
overactive
oversharers so you went on a three-hour
hike you recorded every moment of the
three-hour hike as if the rest of the
world cared then you put on YouTube come
on a three-hour hike with me for a while
it was a very hard
product very risky company right but
take a look at the beta that I get we'll
come back and talk about it there's the
the beta 1.4 you saying this is good I
have a beta but before you use it keep
going down and you will see a standard
error of the
beta 050 so help me out here this is
statistics class I tell you the beta the
raw beta is actually 1.60 the beta is
1.60 and I tell you the standard error
is
05 if I ask you what the bait of a GoPro
is and you are being honest
not giving me a number you should give
me a range right and what's the range
going to be if it's standard is
0.5 um because it's two stand let pause
right there two standard deviation 2 *
.5 is + one and minus one 1.6 + 1 one
point so my Beta could be anywhere from
6 to 2.6 thank you for letting me know
this is very useful and I'm being
sarcastic but that's what you get out of
the
regression regression bet is a noise
you saying what's the adjust beta I'll
come back and talk about the adjust beta
in a moment but once in a while you
might think you hit the jackpot and your
beta will look incredibly good you get
you should get even more terrified of
what you've just
discovered I've saved this beta page for
25 years the beta page I got for Nokia
this is right after the first Bloomberg
terminals arrived at at at at
NYU G on typed in noia and I get a a
regression that's almost perfect every
point is on the line the r squ is close
to 100% the standard eror is close to
zero so why is my Nokia beta so much
more precise at least if you think of
precision in terms of standard error
than my GoPro
beta anybody want to try
yeah it's same number of years two years
so basically I so I'm not I don't have
more weeks it's exactly the same number
of weeks that's clear
would so it could be that you're saying
GoPro is more volatile I'll wage if I
took a mature us company like Coca-Cola
I would still get a much larger standard
error for Coca-Cola than for Nokia so
even if I control for that so you're
right part of this is different kinds of
companies but there is actually a bigger
wild card in here that's making the
standard error really low with Coca-Cola
if I ask Bloomberg for a beta it
regresses against the S&P 500 right why
it's very parochial it goes to the
domestic index of the where so when I as
for Nokia guess where it went it went to
the hex my first reaction was I don't
even know this is an index I thought it
was a witches curse andand the
aggression you know what the hex stands
for the Helsinki exchange you're saying
what the heck is Bloomberg going to
Helsinki for Nokia is a Finnish
company Bloomberg is doing what it's
trained to do it's go to local index I
had no idea what was in the hex and and
I took a look and I wish I
hadn't because in 2000 I think Nokia
owned
Finland it was 80% of the hex 80% so
what's this regression a regression of
Nokia against Nokia and what do we
finding the two move together amazing I
never thought that would happen this is
almost a useless regression here's why
the largest single investor in Nokia in
2000 was not a finished investor is
Barclays is part of their Global index
fund and if your barlay is looking at
how much risk there is in noia you're
not measuring risk against a Finnish
index you're running it against a global
index an
msci and guess what happens when you
shift from the hex to an index like the
the what's going to happen to the
standard eror it's going to go up it's a
feature not a bug you're always going to
have noise in your Beta And if you don't
you should worry about what your index
looks
like so your beta is not useful when it
looks noisy your beta is not useful when
it's too precise you're saying when is
my regression beta ever going to be
useful and along the way you probably
say what about that adjusted
beta sounds like it's adjusted right for
something you know the adjust bet is in
the old days Bloomberg actually used to
give away the game they adjusted beta
for every company that Bloomberg
estimates a beta for like 40,000 compan
companies is the raw beta time
67 +33 * 1 the heck are they doing let's
try this out if your raw bait is 1.8
your adjust bet will become 1.53 raw
bait is 1.5 will become 1.33 6 will
become
73 What's Happening Here what are they
doing to every regression beta just
Wasing
towards one what's so magical about one
it's the average ba across Al they're
trying to be helpful the response is
please stop
helping because all they're doing is
taking every weit and moving to that's
what's probably going to
happen but these weights must be magic
weights right to work for 40,000
companies and I want to know where they
came from so I called Bloomberg not the
mayor but the company a while in New
York you didn't know who you were
calling maybe I should have called the
mayor I called Bloomberg and they put me
in touch with the beta calculation guy
at Bloomberg there's actually a guy at
Bloomberg whose entire life is
maintaining this page you imagine how
exciting his life must be was the
cocktail party I'm the beta guy from
Bloomberg dozens of people gather around
for
anecdotes not this guy
was desperate I mean
you I think they kept him locked up in a
basement room and fed him through a hole
in the
wall he was so thankful that I had
called he said so glad you called I all
day to answer your
questions I know about 5 minutes of time
left but I was afraid if I hung up the
phone too soon he might do something
rash so after a few minutes of what I
thought was polite conversation I hit
him with the question why 67 and33 where
did that come from 2 minutes of silence
I can hear papers being rustled
terminals being turned off and on
he comes back on he says I don't know it
was here when I got here I said what I
said he was I was hired two years ago it
was already there don't blame me I'm I'm
not trying to blame you I want to figure
out where those numbers came
from nobody at Bloomberg at a clue so I
had to do my own digging I found the
original Source it was a paper written
in
1971 remember that year for a research I
looked at a 100 companies why only 1971
he hand collect the data that kind of
kept a limit on sample size and he
tracked the betas of these 100 companies
over the 10 years and guess what he
found the bet is tended to move towards
one and the statistical estimates called
a Stein estimate is roughly with this
2/3 1/3 waiting
1971 say how the heck did you go from
1971 paper to a 2001 that Bloomberg
still uses those weights I'll I'll give
you the conduit that that brought it
there the very first beta estimation
service was called bar it's a Berkeley
based service was founded by a guy
called bar Rosenberg who was a professor
of Finance at the University of
California at Berkeley he was a journal
editor of the journal in which this
paper was
published so again he started beta
estimation service guess where he went
looking for ideas oh there's a 1971
paper I'll put 67 and33 this is 197 74
when you started
this and then it becomes embedded and
nobody ever asked where did that come
from there's so much of what you're fa
going to face when you go out to work
there where you're going to see a number
and say where did that come from you
know what the answer is going to be I
don't know it was here when I got here
when did you get here
1965 you've never wanted to ask a
question I don't live rocks and look
under them I would strongly recommend
that you pick up rocks and look under
them because there's nothing here if
you're going to use a beta use a raw
beta what's the adjust beta just tells
you which direction one is if you're
confused about
that then you far bigger problem than
this class can ever solve you want to go
you're at 1.6 to get to one you know how
you get there right go 1.48 1.36 1.24
1.12 1 I don't need somebody holding my
hand saying give me a number closer to
one because I'm really
confused so don't get dazzled by the
adjusted beta part there's nothing
adjusted
about and there's one slice of History
because you're under regression if
something weird happens during that
period that makes the stock move in ways
that have nothing to do with the
market you know what's going to happen
to your beta it's going to move towards
zero because betas measure how you move
the
market remember the sad but true story
of
GameStop this is the stock that got
picked up out of nowhere meme became a
meme stock got pushed up to 400 there's
the stock right it start you can see the
zooming up if I just focus on the graph
and say is this a risky stock your
answer is be of course look at it went
up from 20 to 400 I ran the beta page
and you might not even be able to see it
there but if you take a closer look at
the beta the beta that I get is actually
negative why it's because this stock
started moving and had nothing to do
with the market betas measure how you
move with the market so if something
weird happens during your time period
your beta is going to lose all
connection to reality there's no way if
I'm ring GameStop I'm using a negative
beta so don't be surprised to see a
negative beta for a stock where
something during the 5ye or two-year
period just made the stock move on its
own and we talked about the gaming right
I tell people look you give me 30
minutes tell me what beta you want for
your company and give me access to a
Bloomberg terminal I will deliver a
printed page page with the beta you want
to see I'll try different time periods
different
indices I can even do trade prices bid
and ask prices and by the time I'm done
you want a beta 1.2 no problem I'll
deliver a beta this is why if you see a
banker put up a Bloomberg beta page
another the question you should ask him
or her how many beta pages did you try
before you got to this one I mean they
make it look like a fact like look it's
a Bloomberg
beta it depends on how many tries you
got there lots of gaming going on what
I'm trying to do is dig a hole for
regression betas and bury them it's a
terrible way to think about Bas they're
noisy they're backward looking they can
be subject to
gaming and of course you can always stop
and say I don't like betas at all and
that's why I asked the starting question
what is it that you don't like about
betas if it's the fact that you don't
like to use stock prices I have a
solution for
you I can look at your past earnings
look at your volatility and earnings and
make them at your measure of risk I'm
willing to do that if that's what if
that's the fight you you could even say
well I'm worried about debt how much
debt a company has that's my measure of
risk no problem I can build my my risk I
am not wedded to the beta that I use if
you want a different way of thinking
about risk I'm going to try to come up
with a relative risk measure around it
so it's volatility and earnings I'll
compute your company's volatility and
earnings let's say it's 40% I'll compute
the average for the market let's say
it's 30% 40 divide by 30 is 1. 33 that
looks just like a beta built around
something that you think is intrinsic so
if your problem is you don't like price
based measures I can fix it if your prom
is I don't like the Diversified investor
argument then that's even easier to fix
right instead of looking at beta which
measures how stock moves to the market I
might use look at standard deviation the
total standard deviation I'm going to
use that actually when I do private
company betas because there the owner is
not
Diversified the reason reason I make
such a big deal about choices you'll be
surprised at how many people refuse to
Value companies because they don't like
betas and a few couple of years ago I
was in Omaha for that Woodstock investor
Woodstock I didn't go to the actual
meeting but I actually was asked to come
and talk to a group of portfolio
managers I don't know where they keep
inviting me back because I keep
insulting them so I walked in their 200
portfolio all True Believers in value
investing so I ask them a very simple
question how many of you have actually
valued a
company two people in that room had
actually valued a company saying but
they're value investors they pick know
cheap stocks based on PE ratio low PE
ratio is cheap low price to book they
didn't actually so I said you call
yourselves value investors how come you
don't value stocks you know what the
most common reason was we don't like
Bas
what B is a way of getting discount
rates you don't like Bas tell me what
you want to use instead I'll come up
with the discount we can keep moving
this shouldn't be the fight that leads
you to say I can't do intrinsic
valuation so there are these
Alternatives and I'm willing to put them
on the table if you don't like C the
capm you don't like betas you can go
with relative volit measures that's
steady deviation based that's total risk
you can look at what I call proxy models
right you can look at the size of the
companies that big companies are safe
small companies are risky I mean you're
making leaps of Faith but every
alternative comes with its own
consequences or you can take the capm
and you can start adding other things to
your number saying you know I'm going to
add a premium for small cap stocks is
premium for IL liquid stocks trying to
come up with a discount
rate my basic point is you need a
discount rate you need a risk adjusted
discount rate I'm going to get there by
hook or by crook you don't like the way
estimate bet is tell me what you don't
like I'll replace it with something
that's closer to what you think of as
risk in an
investment so accounting risk models out
there there are you can do accounting
betas you can look at earnings you can
look at qualitative risk models have you
ever seen a value line page for a
company value line is one of the oldest
investment U know I won't even I don't
even know what to call it anymore it's
like a publication used to come up with
one page for a company the old days
before you could access Yahoo finance
you put up a value land page and
basically in every page said for every
company they had this ranking from one
to five one being safest five being
riskiest so they' classify companies God
only knows what went into that
classification but you could go whatever
you choose as your way of thinking about
risk stay with it and convert into a
discount rate that's all I need what I'm
preparing you for is when you go to work
there will be this Grizzle managing
director z b beta stuff you learned in
class that's all nonsense okay don't
don't don't contest it is nonsense
so what would you use instead what would
you like me to use as a risk measure
because you need a risk measure to do
intrinsic
valuation so I'm going to step back from
this regression beta hold that we've
duck for all of you in a finance
class because you ask people where the
bet is come from if it's right after
finance class you say it's a regression
if you've been working for 10 years at
Goldman Sachs and ask you where a beta
comes from you know what the answer is
Bloomberg betas don't come from
Bloomberg they don't come from
regressions they come from choices you
make as a company what are the choices
First Choice what do you do what kind of
product or service do you provide as a
company think about bet is measure how
you move with the market right the more
discretionary your product or
Services the higher your beta will be as
a company CLA what is this discretionary
meanor when I say your product or
service is more
discretionary what what do your
customers
do for you for the customer right you
can delay buying it you can defer buying
it if you're not feeling you can push it
off right the more discretionary the
higher beta why in Good Times people buy
your stuff in bad times they hold back
let me try a little experiment on you
let's take retail it's a huge space with
very different players so I'm going to
classify them into four groups you got
luxury
Rita Gucci Tiffany famo you got
department stores I haven't been in one
in 12 years but I think they still exist
out
there then you got discount
retailers you could go dollar store but
you don't have to go that low could be
Walmart it could be whatever and then
you have grocery
retailers so here's what I want you to
think about talked about discretionary
non-discretionary based on what I said
can you start ranking these which of
these four groups should have the lowest
beta why it's tough to delay for buying
food for months
right we'll come back to grocery stores
grocery store which should have the
highest yeah you can live without your
Gucci you say no no I can't make it
trust me you will be okay
okay so you should expect to see the
highest bait is for luxury retail and
the lowest bait but let's stay with
grocery
stores you got Whole Foods I live in a
neighborhood where I have a Whole Foods
and a rals rals is an extension of
Kroger which is one of the largest
grow what's the difference between the
two
stores I go and buy groceries but in
Whole Foods I can buy organic eggplant
for 4 times the price of regular
eggplant and when I'm feeling good with
mine and I'm making a lot of money I'm
going to go for the organic eggplant but
if I've lost my job guess what I'm going
to die anyway I'll buy the Kroger's
eggplant who cares organic
inorganic within the grocery store space
you'd expect Whole Foods to have a
higher beta than
Kroger I wanted to start thinking about
products and services if you picked a
company and again I'm going with this
trust you told me you picked company I
want to think about what it produces who
it sells to and is it the kind of item
that people have to buy every month
every every week in which case your beta
should be low or it's something that can
be deferred or delayed so that's my
first jop what do you do what how
discretionary is it in economics there's
actually a term we use for this
discretionary nondiscretionary right
what is it elasticity of demand every
class you've ever taken in the school is
in service of my class you know the the
Cal here elasticity of demand if you
have a product with elastic demand
should have a higher V sopia what do we
do companies that Sim should have fire
better but then there is you know I
don't know in bad times for example in
so times lot of people would buy you
know expensive house deor uh you know
expensive classware because it was a
better place for them to store money a
bank oh it's like a collectible that
right some say you know Buy Ms facts
hold their value veryable I think it's a
very small niche of companies you're
talking about whether that's true where
you buy these because they they might
hold their values Collectibles and in
crisis periods we know Collectibles do
well so if you are a Christies you know
what Christies does right sells amazing
Fine Art you might actually find that
your revenues go up in bad times because
people instead of putting their money
into stocks might come and buy picassos
so let's set that aside because we're
going to come back and talk about those
Niche businesses but for the most part
when you talk about discretionary we
were talking about the kinds of stuff
that we can delay or defer that's my
first St so asket about your company
what do they do is a discri second stop
tell me something about your cost
structure what am I talking about when
you look at a company some of its costs
are fixed costs and some are variable
costs that relate to the product the
greater the proportion of your costs
that are fixed costs the higher your
beta will be as a
company you want to explain to me why
that is why would having a lot of fixed
cost make you more risky as a company
because you can't scale them
down have to pay them think of Co right
think of Marriott and Airbnb both
hospitality companies covid hits you
know what Airbnb did it laid off 80% of
its employees sent them home and it
brought its cost structure down cost
structure is flexible what did marot do
it shut its hotels down but it actually
had to keep maintenance and security
staff to make sure people didn't move
into the rooms and decide to make it
their own
they had the fixed cost which means
Marriot is going to have a higher beta
than
Airbnb businesses with a lot of fixed
costs will have higher betas I'll give
you my favorite Target for this for that
the airline business think about the
cost structure for an airine what's the
biggest of
cost now first you got the the aircraft
that's a huge lease cost so fix cost to
variable cost
you can't go to what let's say you
leased it from G leasing you can't go
back to them and say look our planes are
only half full can I pay you half the
lease right doesn't work that way it's a
fixed cost next is let's say fuel cost
fixed cost or variable
cost variable if you can alter your
schedule right but if you already set a
schedule you imagine the pilot coming
out starting to count the number of
people on the plane 1 2 3 4 5 and then
yelling out of the window only six
people on the plane fill it up halfway
let's see how far we get doesn't work
that way there won't be six people left
on the plane most of the fuel cost is
fixed I know the weight can add to them
you go on item by item un unionized
Airline employee cost fixed fix fix fix
fix so what does that mean 95% of your
costs are fixed you ever noticed that
the airlines never have a normal year
they're making billions or they're going
bankrupt it's like watching a manic
depressive in action right everything
gets magnified in both directions and
that's exactly what fixed costs do so
what what do you do what is a
discretionary what kind of cost
structure and there's a third stop I'm
going to make and I'm going to ask you
whether you borrowed money saying why do
you care when you borrow money you
create a fixed cost you did not have
until you borrowed the money which is
interest expenses in Good Times you have
no problem bad times you still have to
make those interest expenses it make
your ultimately betas come from those
three things they don't come from a
regression they don't come from a
service so with that in place let me
talk about how best to estimate
Bas I'm going to argue that the better
way to think about betas is rather than
run a regression is to start with the
business you're in and try to estimate a
beta for the business so you're luxury
retail you should have a higher beta
second stop bring in the cost structure
it's called operating leverage and if
your company has higher or lower
operating leverage in the typical
company you want to adjust for
that and the third stop is you bring in
how much you have as debt into the
process you building up to a beta
starting with the businesses your
operating leverage and your financial
leverage you saying that's not practical
how the heck are we going to do that let
me take you through the
process let's start with that second
step the operating leverage step to get
my operating Leverage What do I need to
know I need to know how much of your
cost of fixed and how much are variable
right I challenge you to pick up an
income statement and start classifying
expenses accountants don't do it you can
make guesses you can say cost of good
sold probably
variable sgna probably
fixed the biggest problem with adjusting
for operating Leverage is not that we
don't know how to do it it's actually
easy to do it's the fact that you can't
get the information and fixed in
variable so we're going to cheat if
you're a steel company I'm going to give
you the average bait of a steel company
if you're a chemical company you know
because I know that if you're a steel
company with a very different leverage I
should be so it is a problem because we
don't have the information it's not a
mechanical we know how to fix it but we
don't have the information to do it so
adjusting for operating leverage we know
what to do but getting the information
and fixed and variable cost is tough to
do adjusting for financial leverage much
easier why because it's information debt
and Equity it's right there it's on so
here I'm going to break betas down into
two subgroups because we often talk
about betas if it's one number you might
have heard this in the context of
another finance class maybe with a
different term but I'm going to
introduce two different versions of
betas the first version I'm going to
call an unlevered beta what's the
unlevered beta it's a beta you would
have had as a company if you chosen to
fund your company entirely with Equity
people often call this an asset beta but
basically saying if I were looking at my
businesses what beta should I have the
UNL
beta then I'm going to introduce second
version of beta called a levered beta in
a levered beta I take the unlevered beta
and ijust for the fact that you've
chosen to use a lot of debt and as an
equity investor it's a levered beta that
you care about because I can take a safe
business and make it incredibly risky By
Boring enough
money when you run a
regression you get a regression beta
right the regression beta levered beta
or an unlevered
beta anybody want to try Le it's Le
right but here's my question how did
that even creep in there I just ran a
regression of stock returns against
market index I didn't explicitly bring
in leverage so how did Leverage enter
the process you're right it's lever but
how did it sneak in
there the returns and the returns are
already lever unless they so let's let's
go go through so if you're a levered
company what happens to stock returns
are going to be more volatile right
because everything is going to get
magnified it is a lever beta but then
think about what Leverage is built into
the Beta it's a debt to equity ratio you
had as a company during the last two
years the last five years it's not
today's debt ratio so regression bait is
unlevered and if you want to unlever
them you have to do the work of
unlevering and we go through that
process but basically you're taking out
the deif effect there's actually a the B
this equation that you see up there is
called the Hamada equation for Levering
betas it's been around since 1971 it's
oldfashioned a lot of Finance academics
don't like it they tweak it the biggest
problem with it is it assumes that the
beta of debt is zero but all of the
market risk in a companies born by
Equity
investors for the most part that's not a
bad assumption it's not that debt is
riskless but there is no Market risk in
there so if you look at a triple B
Double a AAA bond rate what drives that
rate has nothing to do with the company
it's mostly what what's happening in the
T bond market but if you go to Double B
single B Triple C and you take a look at
those high yield bonds guess what they
start to behave more like Equity right
which effectively means that if you buy
a junk bond you're buying a bond with a
big Equity play in it because it then
the equation starts to fray and people
then again like betas they try to throw
the whole thing out I not not going to
adjust for leverage because you assume
the bait of debt is zero there's a fix
if you have somebody who's adamant about
the fact that the bait of debt is not
zero okay ask them for the bait of debt
now come up with they'll give up right
there they'll say use whatever you want
but let's say you can come up with the
BET of debt and there are ways you might
be able to do it there's an extended
version of the formula where you can
adjust the levered beta for the fact
that lenders are going to Tak I mean
intuitively what you're doing is you're
funling off some of the risk to the
lender saying My Equity bait is not not
going to go up as much so we have the
mechanics in place for breaking up betas
deconstructing them we're going to use
that to come up with a beta for a
company where you're not relyant on a
regression I call this a bottomup beta
completely concocted if you want to call
it something else go ahead and call it
so I'm going to make you my guinea pig
okay you're going to start a business
you're going to start a company you're
going to be two businesses pick the two
businesses you can pick a any any two
you
want you want me to pick for you how
about cannabis and
gambling sounds like so much fun right
let them smoke a lot of weed and then go
into the casino who knows how much they
l so you run a casino and you sell
cannabis on the side right two
businesses and you say what's my Beta
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
go back to my office and I'm going to
collect as many publicly traded cannabis
stocks as I can can I find some
not if I stay in the US because us you
actually have very because cannabis has
this Patchwork of legality across the US
legal in some states there are actually
no us companies that I know of that are
cannabis companies but Canada has about
20 of them because it's legal all over
Canada so I find 20 Canadian stocks I
put up the betas for all
20 hang in there can I find publicly
traded Casino stocks there are lots of
those I pull up the betas for all of
them let's say I find a 100 of those I
average those
out are those betas levered or unlevered
they were regression betas they levered
so I'm going to unlever the beta by
taking out the debt to equity ratio of a
typical cannabis company and the debt to
equity ratio of a typical Casino company
I'm going to end up with an unlevered
beta of being in cannabis and casinos
and I come back to you and say look you
told me you were in two businesses you
tell me how much value you get from each
business and your reaction might be I
don't know how much value I get but I
get 80% of my revenues from casinos 20%
from
Cannabis you know what my next step is
going to be I'm going to take a weighted
average of my two UNL betas I'm now
going to have an unlit beta for your
company and then I'm going to ask you a
final question which is do you have any
debt if you say no I'm done because my
unlit but if you do have debt I'm going
to convert it to a debt to equity ratio
and I'm going to come up with a levered
beta your company so the mechanics are
start with the business breakdown come
up with the beta for each business take
a weighted average and then bring in the
debt and the process course would the
betaed Canadian comp what's your average
beta across all Canadian
companies what's your average beta
across all African
companies this is the nice thing about
bet it's scaled
right B because it's scared I can go
Global it actually gives me this
Advantage because and it's an immense
Advantage end of this month two weeks
from now I'm supposed to be in Portugal
and I'm ring a Portuguese company if I
said I'm going to use only Portuguese
companies I'm going to be in deep
trouble because there only 100 publicly
traded stocks in the entire Market it's
a tiny Market I've got to go across
Europe maybe even Global to get my betas
and the nice thing is betas
travel we'll talk about some of the the
questions you might have to ask but I'm
going to go with those canadi so when
I'm done I'm have a beta for your and
why am I doing all of this because I
don't like regression betas right but
where do I get the
20 cannabis stock betas and the 100
Casino stock
betas from the same regressions all I'm
doing is replacing one regression beta
with an average of 100 hang in there
with me what is the benefit of replacing
one regression beta with an average of
100 regression betas
it might not disappear but it decrease
the law of large numbers right this is
in Magic and here's what happens you
have a 100 regression betas the standard
error each of them is high what does it
mean some of your betas will be
overestimated some will be
underestimated you're just averaging out
your mistakes It's Magic but it's magic
that comes from the fact that you have a
lot of
data a bottom of beta will be more
precise than any individual regression
beta he's saying what if I have only
nine companies in my in my pure group
it's still three times more precise you
saying you're making up stuff I do make
up stuff but how do I go from nine
companies to three times more precise
how does sample size tell you something
about the Precision of your
estimate you take the square root of the
number of companies in your samply you
have 100 companies it's 10 times more
precise if you have 49 companies seven
times more precise 25 companies five
times anything beats a sample size of
one which is what you had before I came
along and gave you this average beta a
bottom up beta is more precise second he
was only in casinos till last month and
then he entered the Cannabis business
why it looked very attractive there's no
way regression beta for his company
would have captured that right because
I'm looking at 5 years of returns but
because I picked the
weights I can bring in the canop in fact
I can be proactive I can ask them what
other Sin Sin businesses do you want to
be in obviously you pick the theme
cannabis
casinos who knows what the other
business might be
alcohol and I can bring that into the
Beta as well I control the process I'm
no longer the mercy of opening up BL
Bloomberg seeing a number there saying I
have to use it I'm building up to a beta
it's more
precise it's forward-looking because you
can bring in business mixers and I now
have a mechanism for estimating in a
beta for a company that has never been
traded
before 2021 in 2022 I valued zato and
PTM in the Indian market you know I've
got more heat for doing that than
anything else I've done in my lifetime
but that's a different story there were
IPOs and I valued IPOs I valued Facebook
at the time of its IPO and you know
Twitter at the time of its IPO they're
all on my blog every one of these
companies valuing an IPO what do you
have you have the financials like every
other company but if I went to Bloomberg
and try to look up the beta for a
company that is going public there will
be no data there because there's no pass
prices no pass returns but if I know
what business Twitter is
in I'm going to ask you in in a second
what business Twitter is in because I
want to kind of cut through the haze of
how you get a beta for a social media
company then I should be able to get a
beta for Twitter by looking at publicly
traded companies in that
space which brings me a good question
what know what business is Twitter
don't tell me it's social media it's not
a business just like the internet was
not a business yeah it's advertising it
gets all its Revenue you think advertis
this is why when people say I've
invented a business my point is no no
nobody invents business you find new
ways of delivering all old businesses
Uber did not invent car service guess
what we used to take cars from point A
to point B before Uber came along we
might have called them limo services or
tax cabs ubit invented a new way of
delivering something that's always been
around so when you look at businesses
you might want to look because one of
the one of the push backs you often get
is what if my company is inventing a
business AI I hear that a lot AI is not
a
business you might use AI to be a better
consulting firm which in case you're a
Consulting
business you might use AI to manage
inventory in which case you're a
business so tell me what your product is
and I'll start building up to a beta for
your company is everybody clear on the
mechanics here though you start with the
businesses yeah you said betas apple
right if I there are 10 companies from
10 different countries um what do I
regress the Paya what guys if you have
only 10 companies I would suggest you
regress them against a common index
which would be a global index the msci
if you if you have access to a Bloomberg
you can replace the index with what's
called I mean I'll give you the symbol
for the MS C Global so it'll run the
regression if you're doing this for a
100 companies I would say just the law
of large numbers work in your favor
because using the wrong index is going
to give you the wrong beta but in both
directions that's the great thing about
having a large sample size you can get
sloppy you can say I'm going to use
weekly or monthly it's not going to
matter I'm going to try different Indy
it's not going to matter the bigger your
sample size gets the slopper you can
become in how you estimate B you would
still use MCI world or msci world would
be what I use yeah
so let me make my case and and I and
make this very very real I've know the
last 30 years I hav't valued a single
company with a regression beta as my
Beta every time I get to this Choice
regression beta or bottom of beta I go
the bottom of beta R so I find it very
difficult to think of a scenario where
you say I want to use a regression beta
because it's not working I can't find a
bottom of beta so it's less noisy it's
always updated and you don't need prices
it gives me tools to estimate betas for
companies divisions of companies private
businesses that are otherwise could not
use so if you go to my web page I
actually have betas by industry broken
down to 93 different Industries I have
Global averages us averages Emerging
Market averages people think I do it for
others I do it for myself those are the
beta pages I drawn through the course of
the year to Value companies so value
Steel company this year I just go look
up the beta for steel companies at the
start of the year they don't change that
much on a week toe basis you're welcome
to use them you could I would suggest
you do this at least on a small group so
you can see the mechanics of doing it
because it'll make you comfortable with
what you have to do what choices you
have to make averages versus medians for
instance a lot of statistical choices
but I think the end game is actually a
very simple one to come up with a beta
for indiv it's called a pure play beta
beta for being in a business so I'll
tell you how you know give you an
example of how this will play out in
real real life take a comp like v v is a
Brazilian company but it's really a
global iron or mining company that
happens to be in Brazil so these are the
businesses that V was at where would you
get the business mix for a
company you just have dependent
completely on them they because
accounting requires that if you get more
than 10% of your revenues from a segment
you have to break it out okay so if you
go and look at the Disney business they
have theme parks they have movies now
they have Disney plus is a separate
business a streaming business so you're
dependent on that starting data so the
First Column came from looking at Vol V
broke themselves down into a metals and
Mining business an irono business a
fertilizer business and a logistics
business V also told me how much revenue
they got from each of these businesses
my job is to take those two piece of
data business and revenues and convert
into a bottom my Beta so your first step
once I knew the business is I went
looking for companies that I would use
to get the unlevered
beta so for metals and Mining and iror I
looked at Global averages why with
metals and Mining is global average
going to be a good
choice are commodi a commoditize they
sell into a global market you're an oil
company it doesn't really matter whether
you're in Brazil or you're selling into
a global oil market so there was a slam
duck I used the global average look at
my sample sizes 48 and 78 for chemical
companies because the kind of the
fertilizer companies I used specialized
chemical because fertilizers just
specialized chemicals 693 this is the
great thing about having a global sample
of 48,000 companies is you should never
run into scenario of I can't find enough
companies 693 companies the standard a
saving is going to be huge I can afford
to be really sloppy but with each of
these I've got an unlevered beta for the
businesses so what's the last step I
need to take a weighted average right I
have revenues I can just use Revenue
weights but what's the problem with
using Revenue
weights Disney makes revenues in theme
parks it makes revenues in movies and
makes revenues from streaming no income
at revenues from are all the revenues
roughly the same to Disney or are some
revenues more valuable than
others yes
production margins right you're in a
high margin business revenues from a
high margin business should be worth
more than revenues from a low margin
business
right
Costco their retail business is a low
margin business but Costco also provides
a service business you can get your roof
your air conditioner that's a high
margin
business if they gave me the revenue
breakdown I want to attach a higher
value to their services business than to
the retail business and I'll give you a
way we can do that from that same sample
from which I got the betas I got the
multiple of revenues that companies in
that business traded at so the way to
read this is a typical metals and Mining
Company trades at about 1.97 times
revenues a typical logistics company
trades at 1.14 times revenues he saying
why the logistics business has much
lower margins than the metals in mining
and it's showing up in the multiple so
if I take the revenues that gets from
each business multiply by that I have an
estimated value for each of the four
businesses right those become the basis
what the heck is happening those become
the bases for my
weights B is about 76% iron or about
177% metals and Mining about 5%
fertilizers and about 2% Logistics the
Only Rule is make sure the weights add
up to 100% everything else you can be
sloppy about but the weighted average
now I would suggest picking a company a
multi- bus company you interested in and
breaking it out right Apple what are the
businesses you're going to find Apple
in it sells your phones smartphones you
got
computers is accessies accessories which
we can bundle in with one of the others
but they also have a Services business
right everything that goes through the
App Store they have at least three
businesses and maybe four and each has a
very different risk profile take a
weighted average you want a real
challenge try
Amazon right what is it in what is it
not
in yeah y do we need for cases when one
of revenue streams kindly enables allers
for
example in in some cases drawing those
lines does everybody get Sophia's
question you've been in the Disney theme
park right you've been The Avengers
section of the Disney theme in
Disneyland it rides on how well the
Avengers movie does so in a sense when
one business does well so when you draw
lines and this is the value of the theme
park business you might be
overestimating the value of the theme
park business because it lives off the
success of the movie
business now if you want you don't want
to finesse this too much because this is
not the place if you were doing a some
of the parts valuation these numbers
actually are going to I would pay more
attention to those things but for the
beta I would just say make it a rough
estimate and move on because you can
always come back and revisit that
okay so that's those are the Bas I feed
those betas in a levered beta equation
and here I ran into a bit of a problem
what do I need to lever the beta I need
a debt to equity ratio
right buy business you open up a balance
sheet for Val they don't break the de
down into each business it give me a
total
debt I need market value of equity but
there's only one market value of
equity so I took the lazy route I said I
can't estimate debt to equity I'm going
to give them all the same debt to equity
but I allow to caveat if one of these
businesses was incapable of carrying
debt I might then make some judgments
based on Industrial average of saying
this is the business that carries more
debt but you need that debt to equity
ratio to come up with the lever beta the
lever beta gives me a cost Equity the
equity risk creams of course reflect the
geographies you're in and I have a cost
of equity for each division I don't
teach the corporate finance class I
haven't done it in 10 years but in my
corporate finance class we spend a lot
of time about coming up with cost of
equity and capital for divisions of
companies because to me one of the
biggest sins in investing in companies
is is is using what's called a corporate
hurdle rate you know a corporate hurdle
rate is you come up with a cost C for
the company use it for every project it
is disaster waiting to happen because
you just you don't have to think to
you're going to create subsidization
here safe businesses are going to be
subsidizing your risky businesses this
is a way of avoiding that and the only
way to do this is to build up to a
bottom of beta so any questions on the
process of building a bottom of
betas yes
no risk free rate is a currency choice
you could that was all in dollars you
could do it all in Canadian dollars you
can do it in R so you you want to be
careful if you're bringing them all into
a weighted average that you don't have
different currencies for different
businesses so when you take a project
you can do whatever you want but when
you're Computing a cost of capital for a
company you can have only one currency
in that calculation right the Canada
part will show up in your Equity risk
premium so when you do the equity risk
premium for that business you might say
this business is predominantly in Canada
I'm going to use the Canadian risk
premium which is same as a US premium
because it is in fact a safe part of
Val's
businesses now let me take a second
example in this one I struggled with a
little
bit I was trying to value and Brier in
2004 Brazilian Aerospace company so I
went looking for publicly traded
aerospace companies in
Brazil know how big my sample size was
one was called Empire I said that's not
working for me I said let me expand to
Latin
America I ended up size of one still
inbr and then I said why am I staying
Latin America folks and that's when I
asked the question betas are basically
betas it doesn't matter where they are
so the beta that I'm using for EMB is
the beta coming from Global aerospace
companies which are at that time were
primarily us and Europe based
and that unlevered beta is basically
what I ended up using to get my levered
Beta I remember presenting it in Brazil
people saying but you're using European
company betas and us you know the
implied message that was those are safer
markets shouldn't the beta for Embraer
be higher because it's a Brazilian
company why
not exactly and I want you to remember
the answer that was given when you're in
a risky country the number that captures
your risk is your Equity risk premium
don't make your beta carry that weight
because that'll be double counting
risk you can be the riskiest country in
the world and I'll give you a beta one
that doesn't mean I'm giving you a low
cost of equity because if I multiply
that in your turkey by a 20% Equity risk
premium your cost of equity is going to
reflect the country risk each of the
numbers in your calculation carries a
different weight right your risk-free
rate reflects currency Choice I'm not
going to punish a Russian Company by
giving it at a higher Euro risk free
rate the Euro risk free rate is the
German Euro bond rate the beta for a
company reflects the business choices it
made and the equity risk pram reflects
where in the world it
operates there's one one one exception
to This Global rule that you want to
think about remember the discretionary
non-discretionary
differentiation that I drew there are
some businesses You could argue that are
discretionary in some parts of the world
still but non-discretionary
in other parts of the world I'll give
you my favorite example and this might
not even be true anymore tele telecom
companies now I was always wary about
using because for a long time if you're
looking at an Emerging Market Telecom
company and use develop Market telecom
companies you're effectively assuming
that phone service is non discretion
because in much of the West phone
service is non-discretionary is before
the days of
smartphones but you took parts of the
world there were big segments of the
population with no phones and whether
they would get phones depending on how
well that country was doing so what you
had was phone service being
non-discretionary in the west and
discretionary in Emerging Markets you
see where this leads right when a
computer bait of an Emerging Market
Telecom company it should be higher than
the bait of a developed Market telecom
companies and that's why I have that
Emerging Market average if you're in a
business where you feel that Emerging
Market companies this is a much riskier
business because it's discretionary then
use the Emerging Market
average one final mechanical detail for
those of you who will end up working
outside the
US when people talk about debt in Europe
in Latin America and much of the rest of
the world they're talking about net debt
not grosseries what gross and net what
are we talking about when I ask you how
much debt a company has and you go to
the balance sheet and you look up the
debt on the liability side the balance
sheet that's gross debt that's how much
the company own what's net debt what are
we netting it out
against you take cash on the other side
so let's say you have 500 million in
debt and 200 million in cash net debt
you take the 200 and you can see the
logic here right if I have cash if I
chose to I could pay off the debt so lot
of debt ratios outside the US are net
debt ratios so one of the big you know
challenges or questions I get is should
I use a gross debt ratio or is it okay
to use a net de ratio my answer is if
you stay consistent it doesn't matter
let me explain when I did know when I
did in Bri I used the gross debt to
equity ratio to get the 1.07 and my
lever beta was higher because my de
gross debt ratio was no
19% if I chosen to use a net debt ratio
my net debt ratio would have been minus
3.32% say how is that possible your cash
balance exceeds your debt your net de
ratio can be negative if I use the net
debt ratio my lever beta is actually
lower than my unlevered Beta because I'm
going the other direction if I just stop
there you're saying I'm going to get a
lower beta and a lower cost of equity
shouldn't my value be different not so
fast where does the cost of equity go
into a cost of capital calculation right
what do I need to get to from cost of
equity to cost of capital I need a cost
of debt and I need weights for debt and
Equity when I do the gross debt ratio my
cost of equity is going to go to that
equation my debt ratio is going to be
maybe 15% based on the 18.95% debt to
equity maybe a 15% debt 85% equity and
I'm going to come up with the cost of
capital based on that mix but if I use a
net debt ratio and I get to the cost of
capital calculation help me out what's
go What's My Equity weight going to
be if I have a negative net de it's
going to be greater than 100% hang in
there you got to work if you you chose
the net debt ratio route you got to be
willing to live with this your equity
ratio might be 102% your debt will be
minus 2% you will get none of the
benefits of a lower cost of debt your
cost of capital you can tested out if
you want will be roughly the same in
both approaches because you stayed with
net debt ratio all the way through so I
don't have a problem with you doing net
debt ratios as long as you stay
consistent with that all the way
through so we have all the numbers we
need for cost of equity let's summarize
risk free rate based entir and currency
Choice make sure it's default free
Sophia doesn't matter as much as long as
we consistent because fixing shouldn't
we then prefer the gross St because it
allows us to account for the tax the tax
effects of that I prefer gross debt
there is a tax effect and also the fact
that your net debt ratio can very
quickly dissipate right let's say a 500
million in debt and $500 million in cash
with the net debt ratio what's your net
it's going to be 0% you're act so the
question I would have for you is let's
say you one company with no debt and no
cash and another company with a half a
billion in debt and half a billion cash
you're treating them as equivalent with
the net debt ratio in my world they're
not equivalent the company with the 500
million debt and 500 million cash I
worry about more why because they could
do a stock buyback tomorrow and I'm
going to face a problem so I prefer
gross debt R but again there are fights
you choose to fight and fights you
choose to pass on this is one where if
somebody says I will use only net debt
ratios I'll say okay just stay
consistent the ultimate effect on there
might be a small effect in the cost of
capital but it's small enough that I'm
willing to let it go but be willing I
mean I think you make a good point when
you when you want to make the co case of
I want to use gross debt ratios explain
why you think gross debt ratios give you
a better sense of risk and value than
using debt de ratios it's a fact that
cash can go up and down and you're
treating firms as equivalent when the
net debt ratio is the same and that's
not always the
case so your risk free rate comes from
your currency Choice your beta comes
from the business mix you have as a
company your Equity risk premium comes
from the countries you operate
everything has its place I think the
problem is when people try to do too
much they end up double counting and
triple counting risk but too much I mean
increasing the beta because you're in a
risky Market using a higher Equity risk
frame using a government bond rate I
don't even know how companies end up
being undervalued if you punish them
three times for the same crime right and
that's exactly what you're doing when
you're counting in multiple
places let's talk about the cost of that
I'm going to give you what I'm looking
for and then we'll talk about how best
to get there when I'm looking for the
cost of debt for a company I'm looking
at the rate at which this company can
borrow money longterm today two key
words there longterm and
today first let take the longterm when
you look at the actual debt in a
company's balance sheet is it all
long-term debt no there'll be oneyear
debt six-month debt commercial I'm going
to take all the debt and act as if it's
long-term debt and you know what cfo's
push back why because usually short-term
debt with the term structure has a lower
rate than long-term debt and they want a
low cost to De say I have a lot of
one-year debt why aren't you giving me
credit for the fact that my rate is
lower what do you think the answer to
that
is no if I let them get away with it you
know exactly how they're going to lower
their cost of capital right they're
going to take all the debt make it
six-month debt and say look my cost of
capital went down I can't give them that
escape hatch you take onee debt what do
you have to do at the end of one year
you have Tak no you know the rolled over
cost of one year debt over the next 10
years is it's going to be roughly equal
to the 10year cost of debt so this is
not a fight about you should take
long-term debt I'm saying whatever debt
you take I'm going to treat it like
long-term debt it makes your life so
much simpler and it gives you a much
more effective number what's the Today
part doing in
here matur is not always interest of
existing de exactly I don't want you to
tell me what rate you paid on your bank
loan two years ago don't give me what's
called a book interest rate interest
expensive by by booked
at I want to know what rate you can and
again this actually makes my life easier
because the minute I say that that it's
going to be the rate at which you can
borrow then I know how to get there
right I start with the risk free rate
and I have to add a default spread that
I see in your company
today so let's talk about easy ways and
more complicated ways to get this cost
of debt depending on the company you're
looking at if your company has a
long-term bond trading out there there's
a price the bond and there's a yield to
maturity right if you truly think that
this bond is a clean measure of risk you
can actually take that yield to maturity
and use it I almost never take this
route and I and I'll explain why one is
can a risky company issue a safe
Bond how how would I do that very high
upal in other words if I secure my
safest assets and I borrow against it I
can isue a bond that the rates look low
but I can't attach that to the rest of
the company because it's based on a very
small segment so my problem with using
the yield to maturity in a bond is who
knows what backs up that Bond and what
rate I'm but if you have bonds
outstanding there's something else I
also will generally know about you that
I can use to get your default spread
which is there's a bond rating but is
that to issue bonds do companies have to
have a rating
you don't but they almost always will
because you decide to go to the bond
market and say we've refuses refused to
be rated what is the bond market read
into that message you must have
something to hide so almost always if
you see bonds outstanding you see a
rating in fact there are many companies
which have no bonds which have a rating
just in case they have to issue bonds
and that's a godsend if you're doing
valuation why because you've outsourced
default risk you use moody or snps you
say they could be wrong but think how
much time you sav not have having to do
it
yourself so if you have a bond
outstanding or a rating I can get you
defa but the question is what do we do
when we don't have either what
percentage of companies around the world
you think issue bonds let's see if you
can get that you
know just throw a number out because
it's almost a random you think it's a
high percent or a low percent it's a low
percent if it's Global it's a high
percent in the US the US is has the most
established corporate bond market any
part of the world it used to be 0%
outside the US until about 30 years ago
now Europe it's about
30% Asia it's starting to get 20 20
India is a very active corporate bond
market didn't exist 25 years
ago so for about 25% of companies around
the world I can find a bond rating out
of my 48,000 companies but 12,000 of
bond
ratings I can use said the other 36,000
I'm saying what do I do now so for a
brief moment I have to act like a
ratings agency and thank God they're the
most transparent institution in the
world not because they want to be but
because of what they make public so what
do what do you learn from a rating SC
they give you the rating for every
company they've rated right if you go to
the S&P website they used to have the
eight ratios they used to use they
actually said these are the eight ratios
we use there's very little private
information in this process it's almost
all based on financial ratios so 30
years ago when I said I want to be like
a ratings agency here's what I did I
downloaded the rating for every rated
company downloaded the eight
ratios and then I did some reverse
engineering what do you think I
did what what's the
reverse I basically did a sort so think
in Excel I sorted the companies based on
ratings from AAA down to see and then
I've looked at the ratio and said can I
use the ratios to see what's happening
you give I mean you don't need AI to do
this right this has been around for 30
years you can reverse engineer and I
found discovered two things one is seven
of the eight ratios seem to be along for
just the ride one ratio seemed to be
carrying the bulk of the weight if you
looked at the r squ it was the interest
coverage ratio you know what the
interest coverage ratio is you remember
from
accounting over it's AIT over interest
expense or operating income over
interest you're saying what does it
measure Think Like A lender right you're
lending to a company and its interest
coverage ratio is eight for every dollar
interest expenses at $8 in operating
income you feel a lot more secure than
if that company has an interest coverage
ratio of
three so I latched on to the interest
coverage ratio and I said I'm going to
create a lookup table based on rated
companies but if you tell me what your
interest coverage ratio is I'm going to
guess your rating
so let's take a compy 2002 and three
Embraer had an interest coverage ratio
of 3.56 I used an average income because
remember I have to think like a lender I
don't lend based on how much money you
made last year I look at what you made
you're saying what do I do with the 3.56
how do I convert to rating here comes
the interest coverage ratio table the
updated version of this is on my website
okay again it's not magic I mean it's
not a black box basically I'm taking
rated companies so with the 3.56
interest coverage ratio show if I know
and you're saying why are there two
columns because it's the world is not
fair if you're a large company I give
you a higher rating for the same
interest coverage ratio than if you're a
small company if you're an Emerging
Market company I give you a lower rating
than a developed Market
company so I take your interest coverage
ratio I go across and I look at the
rating that goes with that interest
coverage
ratio the rating goes with the default
spread that comes from the market that
you can update it every month there's
actually a great site where you can look
up the updated corporate default spreads
for
companies so for companies with ratings
don't mess with this just take the
rating don't ask whe S&P is right or
wrong it's not worth the hassle but
companies without ratings you take this
extra step of Interest coverage ratio to
rating rating to default spread is
eventually that default spread has to
feed into your
calculation so with my interest coverage
ratio for embro given that it got so
much of it revenues from developed
markets I gave it a syn I'm going to
call it a synthetic rating you know why
I put the synthetic in there it's not
moody I've made up a rating and I want
to be very clear that I'm unless Moody
puts a little r next to it and sues me
about
this and the default spread with it is
1% so we have the mechanics to do this I
would like you to see again I'm assuming
you are not lying to me when you said
you picked a company see if your company
has a bond rating if it does you're home
free for the cost of debt at least start
that process off and I will see you next
Tuesday so reminder again we have class
on Tuesday and Wednesday of next week
this room 3:30 to
4:45 are you at all concerned about uh
like mood being wrong about their
ratings like